and in five things all potential
actresses should do to keep their sanity
or keep a good frame of mind yeah I
think it's LA because there's that
there's that honeymoon period when your
first year and it's oh the weather is
nice and wow there's so much to do yeah
but that can fade away quickly so right
what are some things that people can do
to keep themselves uplifted well the
first thing I think is to have like a
really good solid group of friends and
you're going to find those you know if
you don't like I didn't know a soul when
I moved out here so like i said i found
that and my acting class friends and
then you know the part time job i had
met a few people that way and then you
start to get to know i don't know like
going to shows going to comedy shows
talking to people booking work i'm
making friends that way anyway so that's
that's super important to have like
you're you're solid community of friends
I think you go being active whether you
want to do yoga or for Jazzercise like
things like that keep you mentally and
you know physically pretty much saying
um yeah and just like be easy on
yourself to like be gentle I'm a teacher
that said that you know be gentle with
yourself so what if you're a
perfectionist because they're usually
hard on everybody but they're harder on
themselves of course yeah it's like you
you already know all the things you
don't like about yourself before anybody
else could say it um it's same same
applies to this perfectionist you're
selling yourself yeah yeah yeah and I
mean study don't be lazy but that I mean
I don't know if that it's I think
everything is in balance like that's the
key to helping me stay happy if I have a
little bit too much of a workload or too
much of a social calendar or to Mina too
little to do which is not usually the
case but you know it's just it staying
in balance I think I remember have a
life outside of being an actor I mean
don't have everything you do every
waking moment have to do with acting
classes or reading about the industry or
talking about the industry you know have
other other things going on we were just
talking about that driving over because
when is it though too much when the life
becomes too much fun and too many
friends and then yeah the other way also
to too much being alone working on your
craft yeah well I think like everything
is cyclical too because there are going
to be times your you know your booking
work and you're working really long
hours and not saying your friends and
then there's going to be times you have
time off you know for a couple weeks at
a time or whatever it is that you do
need to keep yourself busy not laying
around and but yep balance
you